pascal cherki conseiller de paris et
membre de génération s bonsoir pascal
cherki on censure madame merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france alors ça y est
le texte est passé en conseil des
ministres ce matin ils veulent
poursuivre son processus législatif à
quoi bon manifester encore on va vous
savez ici dans l'histoire sociale de la
france qui arrivaient des fois où même
un texte entré en discussion au
parlement et la contestation de la
mobilisation de circuler la loi devaquet
en 86 le cpe en 2005
alors moi je voudrais juste noter quand
même une chose c'est que le conseil
d'état la haute assemblée qui a été
saisie pour avis par le gouvernement a
ordonné une expertise juridique allie
deux choses a dit on n'est jamais trahi
dans des conditions pareilles on m'a
demandé en six semaines de se prononcer
sur un texte c'est une réforme sociale
majeure depuis 45 ses mots et surtout
elle dit ne peut pas garantir la
sécurité juridique du texte de loi à
cause des projections financières
lacunaire du gouvernement donc si même
la haute-assemblée dit bon son langage à
elle avec les termes policés s'en sortir
de son rôle que finalement on assiste à
une gigantesque opération d'enfumage on
voit là où on en est aujourd'hui et moi
je voulais juste faire une dernière 1,6
par rapport à ceux réalisés là ministres
eux mêmes quelque chose qui est bizarre
dans ce pays les français ne sont pas
des idiots concitoyens ne sont pas des
idiots ils ont bien compris ce qu'ils
allaient perdre ce qu'ils allaient
gagner a priori vous avez près de 70%
des français qui ne veulent pas de cette
réforme
bon pourquoi le gouvernement s'acharne
il nous fit dire voilà je choisi de
favoriser telle ou telle catégorie
sociale
mx apparaissent comprendre c'est la
bahia mais il le fait au nom de la
solidarité d'universalité bons mots et
vous avez près de sept français sur dix
qui disent on n'en veut pas on ne croit
pas votre discours moi je serai le
gouvernement je retirer son projet il va
y avoir une avalanche a priori
d'amendements c'est ce qu'a promis
l'opposition est ce que c'est fait pour
faire durer et durer
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce qui attend mais
l'opposition s'avance seul parlementaire
mais vous avez une majorité de godillots
qui le doigt sur la couture du pantalon
le gouvernement après a prévu un
calendrier très accéléré donc au
parlement nous aurons une parodie de
débat à l'imposition jouera son rôle
mais elle n'aura pas les moyens de
d'empêcher ou de bloquer le processus
donc scène avec les réputé plutôt de
gauche qui n'ont ils vont servir travail
sans faire leur travail c'est pas le
débat moi j'étais parlementaire
quand on veut travailler on travaille
mais alors quand on va bloquer on peut
bloquer avec des milliers d'amendements
comme premier par la constitution donne
des armes gouvernement et sur le rythme
de débats et sur les procédures de vote
bloqué qui nous permet de passer outre
l'opposition je les ai vécus dans le
quinquennat précédent
donc c'est pas au parlement que ça va
jouer dans la rue hier par le rapport de
force avec l'opinion donc c'est moi je
serai manuel macro je réfléchirai une
chose il n'a pas été élu pour ça
contrairement à ce qu'il raconte
il a été élu parce qu'ils étaient face à
marine le pen moi je n'ai pas voté pour
emmanuel macron pour qu'il fasse une
réforme des retraites j'ai voté en 2017
pour éviter marine le pen comme
présentaient leur est appliquée aussi
pour justement réformer la france madame
ce n'est pas une majorité
je ne dis pas que les manuels macron
aînés il soutenu par personne dans ce
pays un tiers de la population française
ne soutient entière voilà pour étonner
les 22% la république en marche et on va
dire 10% de l'électorat de l'est
républicain mais vous avez deux tiers
qui non seulement nous soutiennent pas
son passé du nom soutien aux désaccords
et maintenant pour beaucoup je le dis
ici froidement et c'est très grave à une
forme de m
emmanuel macron est en train de devenir
la marie-antoinette du 21e siècle
ça va mal se terminer cette affaire moi
j'entends beaucoup de mes concitoyens
n'a pas que ça à moi j'entends beaucoup
de mes concitoyens et ce n'est pas mon
opinion
ce n'est pas mon avis je donne pas un
avis personnel je dis ce que j'entends
qu'ils disent au second tour des
élections présidentielles
macron le pen je n'irai pas voter et
donc la séoune ya la question de la
réforme des retraites qui est une
réforme scandaleuse et un question de l'
équilibre démocratique qui est en jeu
emmanuel macron de la rue ne devrait pas
s'entêter
cette réforme est impopulaire mais je
renouvelle pas et moi je vais prendre un
exemple ma profession celle des avocats
qui sont plutôt des gens calmes ont
modéré leur dit non je pense qu'une
écrasante majorité ont voté pour le
président de la république je n'ai
jamais vu un tel état de mécontentement
et de colère pourquoi ce qu'ils disent
attendez on a un régime équilibré ont
dégagé etc
on garantit notre retraite jusqu'en 2000
80 et on nous demande de doubler notre
loto de cotisation est de baisser d'un
tiers le montant des pensions
pourquoi et vous pourriez prendre toute
une série de catégories sociales qui
vous disent mais attendez pourquoi moi
je devrais recul est bon ici il s'agit
de tirer un maximum de français vers
l'eau l'égalité ce n'est pas le
nivellement par le bas et l'écrasement
et le tassement de la classe moyenne et
sa précarisation sa prolétarisation c
l'élévation du niveau de vie de
l'ensemble de la population
donc les guérites et d'emmanuel macron
c'est en fait et je vais le dire assez
vulgairement tout le monde d'en bouffer
de la merde non l'égalité dans ce pays
c'est plus personne doit manger de la
merde je m'excuse de le dire comme ça
mais c'est ce c'est ça aujourd'hui la
philosophie politique du gouvernement
le président qui a déclaré quand il
rentrait d'israël dans l'avion à
certains médias que pour ce qui
qualifierait ce qui se passe en france
aujourd'hui de dictature on a vous avez
écouté sa déclaration on dit allez en
dictature vous verrez à quoi ça
ressemble qu'est ce que vous pensez de
cette déclaration moi j'en prends pas ce
terme menace je ne veux pas détourner le
débat le débat c'est nous avons une
réforme sociale qui est injuste nous
avons une contestation sociale une
écrasante majorité de français là
la rejette le gouvernement doit entendre
l'opinion
voilà et le présent de la république
doit entendre le peuple français est là
il ne le sait pas après ce n'est pas une
dictature mais il m'apprend n'est pas
arrivée par un coup de force ou un coup
d'état il est arrivé par les urnes et il
sera chassé par les urnes donc moi je ne
rentrerai pas dans ce débat-là nous
sommes en démocratie
même si depuis tu veux quelques temps
cette démocratie en tout cas ce pouvoir
pour faire passer ses lois a besoin
d'user beaucoup plus de la matraque que
ses prédécesseurs mais nous restons dans
une démocratie
merci beaucoup pascal cherki d'avoir
répondu à nos questions sur rt france